ce nouveau tour de vis était attendu
pour angela merkel
pas question de baisser la garde face
aux nouveaux variants nous devons agir
maintenant pour nous prémunir du danger
de ces variants il s'agit donc d'une
question de précaution si la mutation
s'était propagé dans notre pays
le nombre d'infections aurait augmenté
de façon explosive comme nous l'avons vu
dans d'autres pays
restaurant café ainsi que lieux sportifs
et culturels garderont portes closes
jusqu'à la mi février
il en va de même pour les écoles gros
points de débat entre la chancelière
allemande et les 16 länder ce mardi par
ailleurs le télétravail sera désormais
imposé je cite par tout cela est
possible au moins jusqu'au 15 mars
da c'est ça c'est une absence fois nous
prenons ces mesures à titre de
précaution pour notre santé la santé de
nos citoyens et aussi pour l'économie et
le monde du travail qui serait très
fortement touchée par une hausse
explosive du nombre d'infections geek
si le télétravail est impossible
l'employeur devra impérativement fournir
des masques ffp2 à ses salariés le port
du masque ffp2 devient également
obligatoire dans les transports ainsi
que dans les commerces en bavière cette
décision a déjà été mis en place depuis
lundi je suis en faveur des masques ffp2
parce qu'un même masque pour tous
facilite les contrôles on peut voir très
clairement si c'est le bon masque ou non
je pense que cela permet un meilleur
contrôle et pour moi ce n'est pas
particulièrement contraignant de porter
ce masque
la question est plutôt de savoir si ce
masque sera disponible pour tout le
monde
j'espère que c'est utile et que tout le
monde va respecter cette mesure
nous n'avons pas d'autre choix si les
masques normaux avait été portée
normalement cela aurait probablement
suffit mais c'est comme ça on n'y a pas
d'autre solution
ce que je constate c'est que
l'obligation de porter un masque ffp2 a
été imposée sans envisager qu'il
pourrait être compliqué pour les
personnes à faible revenu d'acheter ces
masques jusqu'ici je n'ai guère vu de
volonté politique de corriger cela la
deuxième vague de kovy 19 est beaucoup
plus de dégâts que celle du printemps
dernier en allemagne les autorités ont
recensé plus de 2 millions de cas depuis
le début de la pandémie
une lueur d'espoir malgré tout angela
merkel a indiqué que les effets des
restrictions plus dures adoptée pendant
les fêtes commençaient à porter leurs
fruits